>> All right. Hey, everyone. Today, I want
to talk about the Google Wave Conversation
Model. Now, it’s important to understand
the Wave Conversation Model as a user because
it lets you understand what Wave is capable
of in terms of the conversations and the documents.
And it’s important to understand that as
a Wave API Developer because it lets you understand
what your robot is capable of, and how your
robot can manipulate the Waves and conversations.
So, to start off with, let’s talk about
the thing that everybody talks about, which
is a Wave. Now, a Wave isn’t actually much
of anything at all. It’s actually a collection
of one or more wavelets that a particular
viewer has access to within the designated
Wave. So, in this example right here, we have
an hour conversation with four participants,
and an inner conversation with two participants,
and each of these are actually what we called
wavelets, and this particular user has access
to these two wavelets, and so, this is what
they see when they see a Wave. Another user
looking at the Wave that doesn’t have access
to that private reply would only see that
outer wavelet. So Wave is actually different
depending on who’s looking at it, because
they may or may not have access to every single
possible wavelet that’s designated without
Wave ID. So, as you can see the wavelet is
actually where all the conversation and good
stuff happens. So, let’s look in more detail
with a wavelet. So, a wavelet is a collection
of participants, and a collection of documents
that those participants have access to. The
documents are a conversation document which
describes the structure--all conversation;
a collection of blips which is each of the
messages, and tags. And there’s also a few
other located documents that we don’t actually
see rendered of a client. So it’s just the
list of everybody on the wavelet, and we’ve
also seen that list whether they have full
access or read-only which is the basic controls
that we have right now in the Wave model.
The time is very simple, just a list of times,
and the conversation document here looks pretty
simple. It’s just a sequence of blip elements,
and each blip having an ID. And this basically
shows the Wave client how that you’d render
each of those blips. We’ll see more complex
conversation document later. The blip document
here is really simple. It’s just basically
has the text of the message, when are we getting
pizza? We also see more complex blip document
later. So, the conversation document, and
this is really cool because it’s what lets
us have--inline conversations, nested conversations,
all these multithreaded conversations are
only possible view the conversation document.
So, this example here has one main blip where
I put a few sentences of the text, and then
I’ve done inline conversations below each
of those sensitive texts, and that’s what
we would call an inline thread in the conversation
document. The first thread has one blip. The
second thread has two blips, and the third
thread actually has an inner thread inside
of it. So let’s see what that looks like
in the actual conversation document XML. So
here’s XML, you can see there’s a blip,
and then the blip has sub-children that are
thread elements, and they specify that they
are inline as an--actually we have the thread
elements. So you can see this is--it’s a
very simple--XML like structure that lets
us specify broader complex, and nested conversations.
Now, the really cool thing about conversation
documents is the inherent flexibility in this
format. So, we envisioned a future where users
and API developers can actually perform something
really like what is called blip surgery which
means that you could move blips around the
inside of the conversation, and you can move
threads around, and it’s all highly flexible,
right? So, this is a really cool future because
it means that you can better carry your Waves.
And, you know, if you see a thread that really
should’ve gone up there, then you would
simply drag and drop it over there. And this
is the flexibility that’s in Wave, and it’s
not in the lot of other conversation from
what’s out there. So, now let’s talk about
the blip document. So, the really cool thing
about the blip document is that we can actually
do multimedia rich messages inside of a blip
instead of just doing text. And the way we
do this is we are using the combination of
element and annotations. So, the example here,
the annotations make the awesome hold, and
make the image element show up, and make the
link, link up to across that. So, the elements
are specified in the blip XML, and you can
see, we start with a really basic element;
the line element. And that can have attributes
like alignment whether it’s bulleted, heading,
etcetera, and we have some text, and then
we have the image element which has actually
the route which specifies, you know, where
that image comes from. So those are really
basic elements but there’s a long list of
elements you can have inside a wavelet, line,
gadget, installer, attachment, image, and
then much of form elements to help you get
structured input from wave users. Then we
have the annotations. And in the example I
showed, many of the annotations are used to
style a blip. And then an annotation is a
key in a value applied to a particular range
of characters, and the Wave client may decide
to render particular annotations, particular
waves particularly with our style annotations.
So, for example, from start 17 to end 24,
we have styled a font Wave bold. And that
means that the Wave client is going to render
a character 17 to 24 as bold using, you know,
simple CSS. We also have an annotation for
linking. So from 72 to 76, we’re going to
link off to the picture album. Now, those
are the annotations of the Wave client kind
of special cases, and render specially but
there are also some annotations that the Wave
client sets for its own use but it doesn’t
render to the user. So, for example, the client
is always analyzing the language that Wave
user’s typing, and then it annotates the
characters for--to specify what language it
is in. So here, it says that the entire blip
is an English which is correct with the labels,
and annotation. And then the spelling even
can actually use the annotations to the side
what spelling suggestions you make. So, I
think custom annotation the wave client used
but also the developers can set around the
custom annotations if they want to specify
particular range of text that is important
for the robot. They can just set, you know,
their own annotation that says my robot thinks
it’s important, value equals, whatever.
So, it’s also Wave actually putting data
inside of the Wave for a particular range
of characters. So, annotations are really
cool because we could separate presentation,
and we can store extra data. So here’s the
list of the annotations that the Wave client
considers special, and anything besides this
would just be considered custom annotation,
and ignored by the client. And that’s basically
the Google Wave Conversation Model. Hopefully,
that helps you understand way better both
from the user point of view, and from the
Wave developer point of view. If you have
any questions, please post it in one of our
handy forms. All right? See you later.